THAT STUFF, AS SOON AS YOU GOT
TO THE AIRPORT.
THERE YOU SEE PICTURE OF ME AT
THE AIRPORT.
DID THEY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
REPORTERS COMING IN WITH CELL
PHONES?
>> Transl
>> Reporter: NOT AT ALL.
THERE ARE A LOT OF DECISIONS
MADE THAT SOMETIMES SEEM
ARBITRARY.
AND LITTLE EXPLANATION AS TO THE
REASONING OR THE REASONS WHY
BEHIND IT.
FOR INSTANCE, EVERY DAY OUR
TRIPS WERE VERY STRICTLY
CONTROLLED.
WE WOULD ONLY FIND OUT MINUTES
BEFORE WE GET ON THE BUS WHERE
IT IS WE'D BE GOING AND WHAT IT
IS THAT WE WOULD BE SEEING.
EVEN WHEN THESE WERE MAJOR
ORGANIZED GOVERNMENT EVENTS.
THEY JUST WERE NOT REALLY
TELLING US A LOT DURING THESE
COUPLE OF DAYS THAT WE WERE IN
THE COUNTRY.
>> I TAKE IT THEY GAVE YOU NO
OPPORTUNITY TO GET CLOSE TO THE
LEADER KIM JONG-UN.
THIS WAS NO OPPORTUNITY LIKE
DENNIS RODMAN, THE FORMER NBA
STAR.
HE HUNG OUT WITH KIM JONG-UN.
THE JOURNALISTS WHO WERE ALLOWED
IN IN THE PAST FEW DAYS, YOU
WERE KEPT PRETTY FAR AWAY,
RIGHT?
>> Reporter: INITIALLY WE
WEREN'T EVEN ALLOWED TO FILM
HIM.
BUT THEN THAT CHANGED AS THE
DAYS WENT ON.
WE SAW HIM AT EVENT AFTER EVENT.
AND THIS WAS KIND OF ODD.
HE JUST OPENED A NEW MUSEUM HE
BUILT.
IT LOOKED LIKE A MULTIMILLION
DOLLAR INSTALLATION DEDICATED TO
THE HISTORY OF THE KOREAN WAR OR
THE NORTH KOREA'S VERSION OF
THAT HISTORY.
WHILE I WAS KIND OF WANDERING
THE HALLS LOOKING FOR A
BATHROOM, SUDDENLY I CAME ACROSS
KIM JONG-UN ABOUT A DISTANCE OF
15 TO 20 YARDS FROM ME WALKING
DIRECTLY TOWARDS ME.
IT WAS THE LAST THING I EXPECTED
TO SEE AFTER ALL OF THIS
GOVERNMENT CONTROL AND SECURITY
GUARDS REALLY TREATED US LIKE
CHILDREN AND PUSHED US AROUND
FOR THE PREVIOUS DAYS.
AND I RAN TO GET OUR CAMERA MAN
DAVID HOLLEY WHO MANAGED TO GET
HIS CAMERA UP IN TIME AND THIS
APPEARED TO BE A NEW THING,
CERTAINLY FOR A NORTH KOREAN
LEADER TAKING A TOUR RIGHT
THROUGH A GAGGLE OF FOREIGN
JOURNALISTS.
SOMEONE CALLED OUT A QUESTION TO
HIM WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE FOR THE
REST OF THE WORLD.
HE DECLINED TO ANSWER, BUT HE
DID GET VERY UP CLOSE AND
PERSONAL WITH THE CAMERA LENS